that
if a man should be able to divorce a
woman if let's say like i get married
right and i gain a hundred pounds
and he's no longer attracted to me so
i'm i'm gonna look like a different
person do you think he has a right to
divorce her or vice versa for a man and
woman yeah sure we could do vice versa
like i said there have to have been many
steps
so a man's just gonna see his woman
getting fat
and just not saying anything and then
wait till she gets to i don't know
however
yeah
so
would you guys
would you guys have a problem then if a
guy said to you hey like i love you
but you're getting but you're gaining
weight like you've gained 20 pounds the
last six months if you keeps going on to
this route then like i i don't see us
staying together but he's honest with
you he's giving you the opportunity to
lose it so at least he's being honest i
will say this as a man right yeah if a
man
men and women forget men men and women
should find each other attractive they
should find each other attractive
sexually right that's the main key of
keeping the spark in your relationship
and if somebody is um
if if you know your partner is
not finding you attractive because of a
certain thing
it's on you as a man or a woman to say
okay cool
i need to try and get
that person that i've committed to
to find me attractive again men or women
doesn't really matter do you know what i
mean yep
and
that it just made me think about um
how
women will
and maybe some men do it but i haven't
heard that in that type of situation but
women will
do the go to the nine to get a man but
once they've gotten them they'll die
back and they won't they won't do what
they did to get them and the man's like
wait this is what i was expecting
you
you changed
and so i think that
that's
kind of similar but what you were saying
like the conversation and or what pearl
was saying how he says hey you've gained
some weight i would respect that and if
i didn't if yeah i took it and i was
like you know what i'm not getting no
way i'm just a little bit
and
i gained more weight more weight and i
was not
like yeah not smart about it or just
um naive about it and he was like you
know what i told you and you didn't take
the steps to change so is it with
anything i would respect it too to be
honest i mean i think like after you
have a kid like like give me a couple
months after you have a kid
more than a couple months
but like
i don't know i feel like i see a lot of
girls like the second they get a ring
just like let themselves like they gain
so much weight
and i'm like
yeah even even in a relationship because
they feel like they've got what they
want yeah but i feel like also men
encouraged that as well like there are a
lot of men yeah that's true this is not
even exciting because they don't want
their woman being attracted to other men
they don't want their women to be it's
an eager thing
yeah
they will want their women to get bigger
because they don't want their woman
being attractive sorry they don't want a
woman being attractive to other men but
the other the other but do those same
men get angry about those women gaining
weight no like because they like it
they've encouraged you yeah they want
you to be
they want you to be unattractive to
other people but then where is the like
you know where's the balance
where's the best
there's also men that lie to women and
say like that like they're attracted to
their wife when they're really not
anymore and they're not like how many
guys do you think really have the balls
when they're girls gaining weight that
they love to like say that depending
i i was that guy really you said that to
a girl i was that guy if when
my partner was gaining weight i said
listen babe
you're getting a little weight
do you know what i mean
like i was the devil
really yeah like
i was lying but but the thing is let me
make that but but let me but let me tell
you something right
women
lie to other women they lie to their
friends and so when
go on
no this happened someone on our team i i
said look it i would i said i was trying
to lose 20 pounds you don't need to lose
20 pounds i'm like look i used to be 20
pounds lighter i was hotter than you
weren't hotter than why i'm like i know
i was like
it was in one of my vlogs
i don't want to like because she's
really nice i like her but like people
like you know her yeah but i'm just like
why do we like why do we lie i think
it's because like we just you know we
want each other to feel good yeah and
everything is hard stop lying to your
friends like
stop lying to your friend let her go let
her go
let her go
i think especially when you
don't know them that well
and
that's when it's hard to be more
truthful
and so you know like obviously i'm
getting telling you a little more i
think i can be a little much with you
but like i also haven't known you like
from yeah or from your future you know
but
um i think from what she was trying to
do is just you know make you feel good
also we're a little drunk
you know a lot of things are coming into
play oh i get it i think it's like we
have
a natural like inclination to not hurt
each other's feelings for sure and which
brings me on the line it's because guys
guys will see the guy and be like bro
like
your lips [ __ ] dry bro
like get some [ __ ] like no i'm saying
nobody like get some [ __ ] comics or
some [ __ ]
like i mean
we're okay with that but if a woman says
that to another woman mm-hmm it's like
the world
ended and i think it is
when it comes to
like we're talking about weight when it
comes to weight and women or just
certain things in women
if you talk about it in a negative way
or if you say like hey like you're
getting you're looking a little chubby
there you go you're jealous you're just
jealous you're just jealous oh my gosh
because it's been like
it's like
when it comes to that there's there
hasn't
been a way to like that's been expressed
right to teach us hey it's okay to
out of a loving way tell your friend
that they are doing something wrong
that's when
that's why
i say that when women cheat they ain't
gonna say nothing cause it's like oh
they're not gonna be like girl like you
cheating on him
and they're gonna be like go ahead girl
exactly
and
you can do better than him anyway girl
yeah
said that to your partner and she got
upset
that goes back to what i was saying
earlier how you
accountability in yourself and taking
what how that person says it
and how you how you take it and so
people say they want people to be honest
right
but when they are honest they can't take
the honesty
and the thing is as a as men we don't
understand that it's like because we're
honest with our friends and
like we speak honestly yeah when it
comes to a woman it's like
when you go back to
do women want a man that wants to lie
they say oh men are liars
they're lies because they're lying
they're lying because they want to
[ __ ] keep you cool
because you can't take the [ __ ] truth
like we we lied to you because you can't
take the truth or do men also also not
give women the opportunity to take that
truth so you're not thinking
you said men like men don't men don't
tell the truth because women can't take
it right am i wrong a lot of women can't
take it okay not all but a lot of women
okay i'm going to talk about exceptions
yeah there are actually a lot of women
that can take the truth but men are a
lot of men are coward and that's just
facts i agree with that that's a lot of
facts but you have to understand that
but understand that men yeah
men essentially are very biological
biological creatures so
they're thinking about at the end of the
day getting sex from you mm-hmm at the
end of the day they're thinking about
getting sick
so they're thinking what can i say or do
to still get sex
and if they know that if they need to
keep you happy and not and lie to you to
get sex
a lot of men will do it but a lot of men
can get sex elsewhere but the reason why
just me personally the reason why people
say that me personally i'm
controversial
i'm not gonna lie to you i'm like yo
i don't care if about getting sex from
you i'ma tell you the truth oh but the
thing is the last 10 guys have lied to
you
the last 10 guys have lied to you
because they wanted to get sex from you
yeah do you understand so when you come
across me
it's like
oh
oh my god this guy he's a misogynist
it's like no the last 10 guys told you
what they wanted to tell you because
they wanted to get in your panties my
dear mm-hmm i'm not going to tell you
that because i want to i might want to
get your panties but i don't care but
i'm still going to want to tell you the
truth
and whatever happens after that happens
after that do you know what i mean yeah
and you know what it's like and it's
funny
whether they choose to go with that
after you told them to choose well and
it's funny because i feel like men would
probably have more success with women if
they were more honest because because we
don't respect it we can tell if you're
just gassing us up that's what it is
especially right well that's why
nowadays um like if a guy is into you so
soon and he's like all in like right
away we don't we're like why we're like
what's going on here
hold the [ __ ] up
like what's going on